second question is in the midst of all the death
that has occurred thus far with the coronavirus or
any deaths for that matter a lot of well-meaning
christians and non-christians want to know what
happens when a person dies a scripture that is
often misunderstood is second corinthians 5 9. the
quote is often used absent from the body could we
present the lord could we go through this context
to see what the passage really means no i won't
do that that's not the way to study the bible
you study the bible from the beginning
there is a law of bible study which says
it is called the law of first mention the way
you study the bible affects whether you arrive
at truth or you become bogged down in error
when jesus was explaining who he was on his
mission to the two disciples on the road to
emmaus the bible says and beginning at moses
and all the prophets he expounded unto them in
all the scriptures to study the state of the dead
you do not go to second corinthians you go to
genesis chapter one two and three to establish
the root of the teaching of the state of the
dead for instance in genesis 2 7 the bible says
and the lord god formed man of the dust of the
ground breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life and man became a living soul now the reason
why you started the root because the branch
cannot change the root are you following me the
branch cannot change the root it is the root that
guides the branch and so genesis 2 7 says and the
lord god formed man of the dust of the ground this
is important breathe into his nostrils the
breath of life and man became a living soul
if you examine that verse microscopically it does
not teach that man was formed from breath and dust
man was only formed from dust not breath only from
dust in genesis 3 when god spake to adam in verse
19 he says in the sweat of thy face shall thou
eat bread till thou return onto the ground for out
of it was thou taken for dust thou art he doesn't
say dust and breath thou art he says dust thou art
in uh psalm 103 verse 14 the bible says for he
knoweth our frame he remembers that we are dust
not we are dust and breath when abraham met with
god and he was discussed trying to negotiate for
the salvation of sodom abraham said behold now
verse 26 i have taken upon me to speak into the
lord which amber dust and ashes abraham said
i am dust and ashes. nowhere in the bible are
we taught we are made from dust and breath we are
made from dust now when you have that fact in mind
then you go to chapter 3 of the book well chapter
2 verse 19 and out of the ground the lord god
formed every beast of the earth and every fowl in
the air and brought them unto adam to see what he
would call them what that teaches us genesis 2 7
and genesis 2 19 that people and animals were made
from the same substance now you go to ecclesiastes
3 19 and it says for that which befalleth the sons
of men befalleth beasts befalleth means
to happen too what happens to a person
happens to an animal even one thing befall of
them as the one dieth so dieth the other am i
going too fast let me slow down as the one dieth
so dieth the other ea they have all one breath
now you keep this in mind you go back to genesis 3
now and you read from verse 17. let me pray again
father give me wisdom as i deal with this most
important topic in jesus name i pray amen elohim
tells us clearly this subject will be the one the
devil uses to deceive many nations that and the
fact that sunday is the sabbath genesis 3 17 and
unto adam he said because thou has hearkened unto
the voice of thy wife and has eaten of the tree of
which i commanded thee saying thou shalt not eat
of it curse is the ground for thy sake now god
didn't say curse is the breath on the ground he
only cursed the ground because adam was made from
the ground he was not made from the breath are you
following me so god only cursed the ground where
adam came from cursed is the ground for thy sake
in sorrow shalt thou eat of it all the days of
thy life thorns also and thistles shall it bring
forth unto thee and thou shalt eat the herb of the
field verse 19 in the sweat of thy face shalt thou
eat bread to thou return onto the ground this
is the rule teaching of the state of the dead
when you die you return onto the ground now
because man was made from the ground genesis 2 7
because animals were made from the ground genesis
2 19 they both go the same place ecclesiastes 3
19 for what with that which befalleth the sons of
men befalleth beasts even one thing befalleth them
as the one dieth so they have the other ye they
have all one breath all go to the same place
all are of the dust all turn to dust again so
anyone who argues when a human being dies the
person goes to heaven must also say when the dog
dies the dog goes to heaven because the bible says
they both go the same place because they both
came from the same place which is the dust of
the ground this is why it is essential to study
any bible subject from where it is introduced and
there's nothing in second corinthians that can
change this fundamental teaching you go back to
where you came from let's read verse 19 of genesis
3 in the sweat of thy face shalt thou eat bread
till thou return unto the ground for out of it
was thou taken the question becomes where was he
taken from the ground he was not taken from heaven
the breath came from above with god he goes back
to the dirt he does not go back to breath he goes
back to dirt animals that die go back to dirk in
genesis chapter 7 the story of the flood who died
in the flood man cattle beast and creeping thing
all in whose nostrils was the breath of life it
includes the man the cattle the beast the creeping
thing and the bible says all in whose nostrils
was the breath of life god breathed into the
nostrils of adam the breath of life that breath
of life was in the cow the dog the horse the fish
they died they all go the same place what genesis
3 teaches us there is a principle i call it
the principle of return at death you go back to
your origin no human being originated in heaven
when you understand that you realize whatever
is in second corinthians cannot teach when you
die you go straight to heaven because it would
overthrow the fundamental principle in genesis
that you return to your source of origin are
you following me this is the ground and so the
story of lazarus and the rich man people use
that no no no you start at the beginning and
there's nothing in luke 16 the story of lazarus
and the rich man that can overthrow the fact
that as a principle has been laid down
by god in speaking to adam you go back
to the dirt and so everyone who dies goes back to
the dirt every animal who dies goes back to the
dirt now let's read ecclesiastes 3 19-21 for that
which befalleth the sons of men befalleth beasts
even one thing before them as the one dieth so
there's the other here they have all one breath
all go unto one place all are of the dust all
turn to dust again who knoweth the spirit of
man that it goes upward and the spirit of a beast
that is going downward and after solomon says how
can you say that this the man's spirit goes up and
the animal spirit goes down he tells us they go
the same place that is the dust when you study the
root of the teaching nothing subsequent to that
can change that root that root then guides your
teaching so second corinthians the passage does
not teach when you die and the first doesn't say
to be to be absent from the body is to be it seems
to be absent from the body and to be with the lord
whenever time that will be it does not suggest an
immediate following all right when you die you
go to the dust that's why christ is coming back
to raise people from the dust daniel 12 2 and
many that sleep in the dust of the earth shall
awake some to everlasting life and some to
everlasting shame and everlasting contempt jesus
said in john 5 28 marvel not of this that the hour
is coming into which all that are in the graves
shall hear his voice and sound come forth some
people say well the body goes to the ground
and the soul goes up no no no no man became a
living soul all of me is a soul and when i die
i die when joseph went down jacob went
down to egypt he went down with 72 souls
revelation 16 the the the plague on the sea and
the second angel poured out his vial upon the sea
and it became as the blood of a dead man and every
living soul died in the sea what are the living
souls in the sea fish we are living souls a fish
is a living soul a dog is a living soul you must
be careful how we use the word soul when you die
you go to the grave as jesus did next question
you